okay so
let's play what should we play sidsilian
or e5
i mean let's play e5 let's keep things
basic okay knight f3 knight c6
[Music]
because that is the move most people
probably play okay so
as we discussed with alex um
knight f6 allows the fried liver and the
way to avoid the fried liver
is to develop your bishop first that is
the move that i've actually played
bishop c5 gioco piano italian game
and the evans gambit so
the yemen's gambit has named after
captain evans
from the 18th century has withstood the
test of time
i will delve deeply into the history of
the evans gambit after
the game but the bottom line what is the
idea of the evans gambit
because it's a move that strikes a lot
of people as mysterious who can lay out
for me the main idea like what do we get
in return for the pawn i'm not gonna
take it yet i will take the pawn
uh but i want somebody to predict uh the
actual follow-up first
right so the idea is to play c3 with
tempo
and the second thing that happens is
white gets access to the b3 square so
this idea of queen b3
is actually super dangerous so the move
bishop c5 here actually
walks into d4 so we need to choose very
carefully where we put our bishop and
most
squares have a drawback d6
has the drawback of sitting on the
bishop on c8 not being able to develop
it
bishop a5 makes the bishop somewhat
irrelevant and it allows potential
bishop a3
bishop f8 undevelops the bishop that
that will make it very hard to develop
the king set in a timely fashion that
basically leaves
one square which doesn't have as many
drawbacks and that is e7
there are other moves the other moves
are possible but this is the line that i
actually
learned i think this is the safest line
for black yeah so white's gonna have a
big center but i'll show you guys how to
disarm this
okay so d4 now the
essence of this line is
we need to get rid of this bishop on c4
this bishop on c4 is the source of all
evil
and we need to get rid of it at all
costs now the way to get rid of it is
kind of awkward or at least it looks
awkward but
as we say you can't make an omelette
without breaking some eggs it's more
important to eliminate the bishop from
this diagonal
than it is to do anything else and after
the game i'll talk about some of the
reasons
why other moves aren't as good here the
move is knight a5
now yes you guys might look at this and
say wait a second can white play knight
takes e5
simultaneously defending the bishop yes
he can but that's the drawback of
gambits right when you accept a gambit
you have a bargaining chip and you can
give this bargaining chip back up
for certain other benefits here the
benefit is going to be obvious we get
rid of white's main attacker
this is what's actually going to happen
and in addition to this we can strike in
the center with tempo
what am i talking about here it may seem
that white is still better because he's
got
very nice control of the center but we
have something to say about that ladies
and gentlemen we have something serious
to say about that no you ain't
here we go we open up the bishop and we
develop the queen
with tempo all with tempo this is theory
this is a legitimate line for white
but white is slightly worse here so e
takes d5 queen takes d5
forks the knight of the pawn in that
position
uh just to give you guys a little bit of
visualization practice
can white defend both at the same time
after he takes queen takes what can
white
do to defend both the knight of the pawn
at the same time knight e3
but the move knight e3 is a clear
concession right you're like okay
dialing everything back dialing
everything back it blocks the
development of the bishop to f4 which is
its best square
and i want you guys to look very
carefully at these pawns does anybody
know
what these are called there is a
specific name
for the c and d ponds that are isolated
from any neighbor
it's like isolated ponds but they're not
isolated because they're defending each
other they're like marooned
so it's called hanging ponds it is upon
island
yes but these specific pawns are called
hanging pawns
i'll show you guys a couple of lines or
hanging pawns originate
like i'll show you and it's called
hanging pots because they're like sort
of isolated so we say that they're
hanging
okay so we got to bring the queen back
and then we're just going to complete
our kingside development knight f6 and
castle
now the hanging pawns are kind of like
both the strength and weakness like
there is strength because they're in the
center right you're controlling the
center they are a weakness
because they are actually quite easy to
attack uh and and they can easily
sort of buckle and melt in the heat of
the moment
black is slightly better here also
because i have the two bishops and it's
a pretty open center which means the
bishops are kind of good here
now from a logical perspective we have
one more piece that we haven't developed
which is the bishop
where do you guys think i should develop
it and this is not a
one answer question there are several
cases to be made here you can develop it
to several squares
one idea is to put it on e6 but
the way that the daniel style move is of
course the fiance
uh fianchettoing the bishop aims it at
white's king which is more aggressive
okay c4
but we gotta clear everything up now
the problem with fianchettoing the
bishop right
is that it it leaves the f5 square
unattended so
after we play bishop b7 the move knife
f5 or
knight f5 is very very dangerous and
white actually starts an attack so
believe it or not as tempting as it is
to fianchetto we actually don't want to
bend kiddo but before we do anything
okay and i want this to make sense we
need to slow down the progression of
these pawns
it's like we need to put that that that
uh we need to put a speed bump
and that's the way i refer to it like my
parking garage just had speed bumps
installed you don't boo
no no no no c6 slow down speed bump c6
makes it a lot less effective for white
to play t5 because if he does
then we're gonna take it and he's gonna
be end he's gonna end up with an
isolated pawn
okay a4 well um we can play a5 to slow
the pawn down but we don't really need
to we can actually let this pawn get to
a5
and as many of you have indicated we now
play bishop e6 in order to increase our
control over the d5 square
does this make sense now the move a4 is
actually very good
um because white grabs space on the
queen side but he's got to be careful
not to overextend himself
okay well c5 allows d5 right c5 allows
d5 and white as a
protected passer now our main plan here
and this again should make perfect sense
to everybody is to find a way to get to
these pawns we need to win these funds
but we also need to be attentive to what
weaknesses have been created as a result
of white's last move a4
this has created a hole on the b4 square
and guess what the bishop on e7 ain't
doing very much
so let's employ the bishop let's put it
on a square where it's actually getting
stuff done it's getting some serious
stuff done it's attacking the knight
why is this pin dangerous what specific
property of this pin makes it very
unpleasant for white i've talked about
this
several weeks ago when i first started
the speedrun
is a very specific way that you can
evaluate how dangerous pins are
exactly no pawn supports the knight
which means white has to assign
the task of defending the knight to a
piece and that has the potential to
block
white's defense of other pawns which is
exactly what happens white
should have fianchettoed the bishop
instead that was the lesser evil
yeah queen takes d4 queen takes d4 and a
hanging pawn has collapsed
and the other one collapses with it
which is often what happens when the
hanging pawns are mishandled and hey
they're very easy to mishandle even gm's
do that
now by the way we're ready also to put a
rook on d8
okay queen b3 this is an interesting
move
so the first thing that jumps out to me
is the fact that it leaves the bishop
undefended
but after oh we have something sexy
after queen takes d2
yes we should do this now of course
radcliffe
will take our bishop on b4 which may not
seem like a very good trade for us like
hey
why why am i giving this bishop up i
could have protected it with a5
but there is a very specific follow-up
here and you guys are so freaking sharp
this is a pin
boom goes the dynamite knight e4 boom
boom and there's no way to defend
against both at the same time the knight
is hanging the pawn on f2 is hanging
both would be devastating
and a move like knight d1 is not
possible because of course the knight is
pinned
so this is what tactics is right tactics
is like a way to hack
logic because logically you wouldn't do
this right logically speaking
you wouldn't want to give up this bishop
for this bishop
uh the red bishop for you know the blue
bishop for the red bishop because
our bishop is better but because of this
very specific tactical property
uh it tactics supersede
verbal logic that's how you should think
about this right that's why it's so
important to be able to
spot tactics and spot tactical
properties like pins and forks and
hanging pawns and all of that stuff
because it allows you to enrich your
play
logic is great but logic doesn't take
you very far if you can't also
supplement it with concrete tactical
vision if that makes sense now rookie 2
doesn't actually work it only defends
the f2 pawn and doesn't defend the knife
which is hanging
and that's exactly what happens we
simply take the knight with our queen
not with our knight because now our
queen is hanging
and we don't take the rook because
knight takes e2 one mistake i see people
making
is actually thinking that you can take
the rook i know that sounds really weird
when i say that now
thank you nostradam but after knight
takes e2 people think wait i'm pinning
his queen
but wait no you're not because that very
same queen is already moved by taking
the rook
don't forget about that what should we
do now unfortunately radcliffe collapses
here
and uh we rip the rook and now
everything collapses because once the
knight blocks symbolically the second
hanging upon actually does
fall bishop takes c4 and if rook takes
c4 then we take the knight with
checkmate
rook is actually paralyzed the game is
over
uh piston says hi daniel i like your
stream and i appreciate you
but for people who cannot even process
the most simple things
you say it is very hard well again i do
want to make it
clear a very good game rather radcliffe
uh this is a place where you can ask
questions you can ask me to repeat stuff
and i really mean what i say i'm not
just trying to be nice
if if you feel like i'm going too fast
zero shame in asking me to repeat
something or to reword it explain it a
different way that's what learning
freaking is
um and like i said i i feel you i've
been in classes where i feel like my
professor
for a teacher created an environment
where people were embarrassed to say
they don't know or embarrassed to ask
questions i think that's criminal
um i think saying i don't know or i
don't get it is one of the most noble
things you can do in a classroom or a
learning
learning situation because that shows
you're engaged and you want to learn
uh and that's what i seek to create so
please don't feel embarrassed and ask me
as many times as you want don't be
obnoxious but it's okay to ask me to
repeat something
okay so the evans gambit
let me talk a little bit chess history
the evans
gambit what can we say about it let me
let me fire up chess base and i'll tell
you guys
when this really interesting opening was
first played
so it's named after captain evans i'm
not sure what his first name was
i'm pretty sure yeah he was a navy
captain lives in the 1700s and was a big
chess fan
i'm pretty sure that that is the evans
the evans gamut is named after
um and let me look i'll look him up in a
second now let me first tell you guys
when this was first place was evans
actually the first one to play the evans
gambit
because often as we know that's not the
case the opening a line is named after
the person a line is named after is not
necessarily the first person to play in
fact
ladies and gentlemen evans was not the
first person to play the evans the first
person to play the evans was mr mcdonald
alexander mcdonnell one of the strongest
players of the early 19th century
played b4 in his match against one of
the strongest french players of the
early 19th century louis
charlema de i'm probably mispronouncing
it la bordene
uh and then labor dane played it like a
zillion times against mcdonald
uh he liked that idea plagiarized
plagiarized the british
french plagiarized british whales then
evans played it against mcdonald
poor mcdonald mcdonald opens a can of
worms and then everybody plays it
against him and evans william davies
evans plays it in london in 1829
and thrashes alexander mcdonnell so i
guess
william evans was that very same captain
it was played a bunch in the 1800s
and it's one of those openings that
remains very very popular to this day
black has several ways to disarm it
but no way to get a big advantage or
anything of that nature
let me go full cam and do some research
on evans who was
mr evans and to do this research
i turn to one of my favorite chess
historians edward winter he always has
some really cool stuff on the origins
of openings the evans gambit by edward
winter
this list of analysis
[Music]
it was appear first analyzed in 1838
thank you stanneck i
almost 1838 an article appeared on the
evans gambit
and uh many people analyzed it in the
1800s
william davies evans 1790 to 1872 that
was whom it was named after
stately british old guy
um it represents an old man in a black
skull cap with a flowing white beard
yes you probably had you know kind of a
very stately british accent and
yes so he developed the evans gambit and
i remember having a seafaring expedition
in 1830 and
i decided to play b4 in the italian
anyways um so william davies evans
and um oh [ __ ] you guys want some drama
some 1800s drama there was a car there
was a conflict
the germans the germans had something to
say about it
because in 18 in 1915
a british newspaper reported that when
the evans gambit was first developed
there was a german player
apparently who also in parallel
developed the evidence gambit
there is a problem who should be
attributed to leibniz or newton
except transfer that to the evan's game
i think no limitation 101 with 10
gifts of subs my man thank you so much
1915 chad's amateur writes the evidence
should be called the german game
a correspondent in one of the leading
german chess magazines
this is from the 1915 edition of the
journal
chess amateur a correspondent in one of
the leading german chess magazines
suggests the opening invented by the
english captain
william evans should in the future be
called the german game
the yorkshire observer budget comments
if the germans choose to proclaim the
whole of the chess openings a sort of
military area and forbid anyone else to
operate therein
there's no reason why they should not do
so it might please them and would not
make the least atom of difference to the
rest of the world
so they're all pissed at each other no
german chess opening
um the field has published an article
written by mr amos byrne
this is from that very same article amos
byrne was a 19th century english player
relative to the absence of a german
chess opening in fact lamented by one of
the leading german chess magazines
so this is basically coming from a
german chess magazine that says there is
no german opening
there is a lot of other nationalities
included in chess openings the french
the english there's no german opening mr
burns says that no mention is made of
the russian opening
but it is pointed out that there are
danish and scandinavian
english a scotch gambit a french a
spanish an italian a greek or vienna
and even lately a swiss opening i have
no idea what that is but where
pathetically asked was the
correspondence is the special german
opening made in germany
he answers his own question by
explaining that in these matters as in
so many others
the germans have been modest in the
beginning always inclined to honor
others and keep themselves in the
background he suggests that the opening
invented by the english captain evans
should in future be called the german
game
another correspondent does not approve
the appropriation of the evans but
suggests that in the future the spanish
opening should be
renamed the german opening four says he
its solidity the enduring pressure which
enables an attacking player to hold on
his opponent
well and now of course there's the
berlin the berlin
little did they know the berlin would be
uh the sort of most famous german named
opening um
the evans gambit invented by captain
evans
yeah anyways enough i feel like i'm
this is getting boring
ah the reason they wanted the evan's
gamut named the german was because of a
game that was played
in berlin in 1848 where the evans was
actually played
this once described as a gift of the
gods to a languishing chess world the
this invention
of captain w d evans did indeed give an
infusion of life to the geoco piano
okay so it caught on really fast super
popular when it was created
so this maritime sea captain creates the
evans gambit
and uh off we go now let's take a look
at the actual
evans gambit or the german game whatever
it's called
so the idea as i've explained is to lure
the bishop to b4
in order to quickly control the center
now
the evans can be declined you can play
bishop b6 here that's actually a
legitimate move
the problem is white can go b5 and chase
the knight away and soften up the e5
pawn
so this is considered to be a little bit
dubious so the logic
as i explained it right is
every square basically except e7 has
a very big drawback bishop c5 allows d4
with tempo
bishop a5 makes the bishop irrelevant
and allows bishop a3
occupying the super important diagonal
bishop f8 undevelops the bishop
bishop d6 sits on the c8 bishop making
it impossible to play d6 or d5
and so bishop b7 is the lesser evil
right because we allow ourselves to play
d6
and we keep the king side somewhat
developed
now if white plays queen to b3
immediately
we can play knight h6 and guard the pawn
when we're ready to castle
so that's not dangerous d4 knight a5
so by the way if we go d6 this is a
mistake
the reason this is a mistake again guys
use the method of comparison
what move is now very strong now that
we've included these two moves
so knight g5 blunders the knight but
you're close you're looking at the right
pawn
again guys don't abandon an idea just
because it doesn't work in one
particular position queen b3 is correct
good good thing that benny watts got it
because knight h6 is not possible
knight a5 is the correct move for black
now bishop takes f7 happens king fa and
there is a vicious trap
which you guys should not fall into to
the untrained eye it might seem okay so
the
queen's being attacked bishop is on f7
let's play queen to d5
this is a mistake and black has a nasty
continuation
nasty nasty what is black's continuation
here this is actually very pretty i
always like it when the queen gets
trapped in the center of the board
in the night on a5 knights on the rim
are grim knights on the rim are freaking
amazing
c6 and the queen is trapped you can't
take the knight because it's
is defended good job you guys all
deserve subs for that
so what is white's best move here what
should white two can white save the
bishop
or does white just lose a piece and lose
the game well the answer is obviously no
i'm leading you on
but what is the move queen to a4 counter
attacking the knight counter attacking
the knight
and if you look at this position the
king is permanently weak on f7 white
controls the center
black's position is miserable so
that's the reason why knight a5
immediately is very important
you need to stop queen b3 at all costs
you need to get the bishop out of c4 at
all costs okay so knight takes e5 to my
knowledge
isn't the best move i think the best
move here is considered to be bishop
back to d3
and then d6 is the theoretical move you
basically give the pawn
back up but you do that in order to
accelerate the pace of your development
right
and queen a4 check here most importantly
doesn't win the night
it doesn't win the night because of our
familiar move c6 which
extends the queen's defense of the a5
knight this is a very interesting
position i'm not gonna delve into the
theory
but if you're playing white radcliffe
bishop d3 is what you should investigate
this is the way to test black knight
takes c5 allows me to take
and go d5 and quickly get my queen out
now you've got these hanging pawns you
don't have your light squared bishop
uh the position is kind of toothless
your black's got a very comfortable game
uh does that make sense so far am i
making sense and again thanks for the 10
gifted subs uh before i mean just
incredible level of support
you guys are gifting them 10 at a time
and i really really appreciate it
okay so castle's knight f6 rookie one is
good getting the rook to an open file
castle c4 is good
i think your main mistake actually a4 i
originally thought was a good move and i
think it is a good move
but you want to follow it up with the
right continuation
now the thing to understand is that this
bishop on e7 it might not seem very
imposing but it's actually a very
dangerous bishop because it's stopping
it like it cements itself on b4 can we
get rid of this bishop
simplifying the position a little bit
and clarifying things
yeah so we can of course we can we can
do that by playing
bishop to a3 and i would say maybe black
is slightly better here very slightly
but really nothing particularly
dangerous the other thing you could do
where could this night go
and for what purpose where can this
knight go in for what purpose
thinking about the hanging pawns being
the main weakness in white's position
remember some of your pieces can be
occupying defensive roles that
is the biggest thing people don't
realize not every one of your pieces
needs to be super aggressive
in this case you put your knight on c2
and this pawn is now solid as a rock it
can't be attacked very easily
okay and if you know that the other
knight defends the other pawn
so both knights are responsible for
hanging on to the hanging pawns
and very slowly you could coordinate
your pieces in the center white is doing
fine white is not
you know swimming in luxury but black
doesn't have an easy way to
expand the pressure okay
so knight c3 bishop b4 and here the
situation becomes unpleasant
now bishop d2 is the decisive mistake
because after this pawn is taken the
position collapses
could somebody propose a way to hold
white's position together
you're almost correct radcliffe it's
just you chose the right piece to defend
the knight with
but you should have gone to b2 right
bishop b2 yup good job guys
and uh at very least the knight is
protected now white black like a try
queen a5
but no you could play rook c1 white
holds on uh the situation is not very
pleasant
white is under tremendous pressure but
you could maybe even beef up the
security by getting the rook to d2 white
is hanging on
okay all right it's not the end of the
world here that's what i want people to
understand
so bishop d2 queen takes d4 and here
already
you're basically losing queen b3 hastens
the defeat but i totally
understand it i mean your position kind
of collapses here if you go knight c2 i
take the other pawn
this is just very very bad uh so
bishop a3 i think really is the is the
last chance you had to keep things
stable i think you played extremely well
in the middle game
it really boiled down to just one move
okay and i think
a4 i think i get why you played that you
wanted to grab space on the queen side
not to put words in your mouth but you
could have also played bishop a3
immediately that was also possible but
in any case radcliffe thank you for
playing the evans
super instructive game and i really
appreciate you putting it putting
yourself out there not to mention all
the gifted subs
appreciate your support keeps me going
not a dumb question at all i forgot to
talk about that sk dude man asks why was
fianchetto bad
absolutely let me talk about that so i
decided at this point to develop my
bishop to e6 with a preliminary c6
why was it a bad idea to fianchetto i
don't think it was a bad idea
per se but there was one very specific
thing i was afraid of can somebody
remind me of what that is
what is it specifically that i was
afraid of by fianchetto and there's two
reasons actually
the first and i'll get to the re the
main reason afterward you guys are
correct
white could play d5 and block the bishop
um and you've got to be careful about
that right now
why does this pawn chain that's blunting
the bishop well i could try c6 to cut
into the pawn chain but you know this
could be a little bit shaky
but the main reason is that white has
this move knife f5 as feingold says
and i don't like this knight this knight
can combine with the bishop on juve
this could get very nasty very quickly i
don't want to delve into the details
here
also queen queen can swing over to g3
and attack g7 this just gives black or
white rather some
extra attacking chances that i didn't
want to allow and so the bishop on e6 is
like the guardian of the king side it
simultaneously pressures the puns
and also it guards the f5 square does
that make sense
okay let's play jupster rexon 1560.
all right so let's do another e4 see oh
no i forgot to play the ninja larsen
okay it's fine
okay i'm sorry dr alone i actually just
forgot c2lo thanks for the t1
this is the french now in the french
what is white's main move
like what should we do against e6 or c6
it's like the same move against all of
these
six openings d4 is correct
and now there's many possible moves
now uh i think and i'm
you guys will roll your eyes at this uh
if anybody was planning on subbing
you're like oh
naredinski's one of those people i'm
going to play the advanced french thank
you and emeritus with 200 bits
but i want to show you guys a little bit
more about how to play closed positions
i think a lot of people need practice
with that
and to quote eleanor roosevelt you have
to do the things uh
you think you cannot do and one of those
is thriving in closed positions uh
not easy to explain but first of all we
go c3 of course we need to
develop the pawn chain and as i've
explained on several occasions
it's easier to understand positions when
you sort of zero
in on what the battle revolves around
what does the game
revolve around here like how can we
how can we summarize how we're
developing here right it's the d4 pawn
who can gain control of this pawn chain
if it's white
why does a big space advantage white is
nice development if it's black
this entire operation collapses and
that's why queen b6 is the theoretical
move
now i'm gonna play a move that to some
of you may seem very odd and i'm gonna
play this move and i want people to tell
me holy [ __ ] oh holy smokes
fractal with ten subs again
a3 i'm so hyped right now this is crazy
thank you fractal
what is the purpose of this move what is
the purpose of this move
oh my lance the purpose is to play b4
and basically
get out of here c5 pawn leave my pawn
chain alone
now obviously it's two pawn moves so to
you guys you might be like well we're
not developing our pieces is this
really worth making two pawn moves over
well yes it is
that's how important it is to preserve
the health of the pawn chain
in addition look at how nice this is
a3b4
this pawn can go to b5 later it can kick
the knight away we can fianchetto the
bishop later so there's all of these
ancillary things that we gain by playing
b4 another 100 bits from ob68
let's go amazing thank you guys
so bishop b2 here is also very possible
which extends the support of the pawn
okay a6 so he's stopping b5 that makes
sense
although it's a little bit slow
now let's develop let's develop our
pieces uh
by the way f takes e5 is not dangerous
for us because it continues to weaken
his king
f takes e5 d takes e5 and i'll explain
that more after the game but that's
totally fine
500 from jiga hearts holy smoke okay
i'll stop shouting now rue wf for the
prime was just really hyped
where do we put our bishop who can tell
me where we put our bishop
and i'm going to write all this down
because there's a lot a lot i have to
explain here
now putting it on the right square
involves seeing a tactic bishop d3
this tactic you have to hammer on your
mind wait a second i'm blundering the
pawn well no i'm not knight takes d4
knight takes d4 queen takes d4 what is
white's move there
what you guys should notice is what i
call a standoff the queens are
have the standoff so logos seven thank
you bishop g6
check well or bishop b5 check right
either move is good
and uh the queen gets lost 300 from
jayru
now do we have to defend the pawn or can
we castle
if you paid attention to what i just
said you should be able to answer this
question
do we have to defend the can be castle
we can castle
because although he's defended against
this move bishop g6
is still an available check so we can
tuck our king away safely
why am i not developing this bishop
because i'm trying to play as flexibly
as possible we know that we have to
castle that's not something you will not
do
but i don't know where i want to put
this bishop maybe i want to put it on e3
maybe on b2 i don't know
that depends on how black develops his
pieces
so what i'm trying to do is make the
necessary moves first
wait for black to put his cards on the
table and then decide
where to put like the discretionary
pieces uh that is like a
sub-battle that often happens at a grand
master level which dictates moves and
people don't always understand that
so i can show you guys some examples
basically it's this posturing right who
can reveal their plans first
so that the opponent can develop their
pieces in correspondence in order to
combat uh your opponent's plan right so
you want to make the flexible moves
first
if he pushes a5 we can just go b5 okay
now we still can procrastinate see
procrastination in chess
can be a good thing i've chosen that one
field where procrastination is a good
thing
we don't need developer what else can we
develop here what can we develop before
our bishop
we can and uh ava and nl you've already
said it
yeah we can develop our knight still
bishop g6 is possible
now even can you repeat for us where
this knight can go
and very quickly guys you should know
this idea those of you who've been with
me
for the whole time of this speed run
remember
remember this idea with knight b3 knight
c5 targeting the weak pawn
same weak pun same maneuver different
transit point flying through paris and
not frankfurt same idea
the e6 pawn is weak now we don't have a
rook on the e file but that doesn't
matter the c5 squares as a standalone
square is really good
so we have this additional idea we might
not have to develop this bishop at all
knight to a4 and knight c5 is a very
important idea here
black is already in trouble he's played
this a little bit passively i'll tell
you guys exactly where he went wrong
after the game
so alex asks a great question why are we
not taking on f6 the reason it's bad
is because we we release the tension on
the position right and after g takes f6
first of all he gets the g file which he
can use as an avenue toward our king i
don't want to give him that
second of all we give him the potential
of occupying the center with e5
i don't drink energy drink i just drink
coffee and i drink a lot of it
okay knight g6 now let's unpack this
move for a second and i'll explain the
details after the game
so now he actually finally is
threatening to take on e5
true should we take the knight on g6
well no we shouldn't
we shouldn't because that allows him to
take this bishop is important
and it opens up the h file for his rook
what should we do
how do we keep the tension can we defend
the pawn on e5
how can we defend the rookie one very
simple very simple chess rukivan
let him be the one to decide whether he
wants to take force your opponent to be
the one to make the decision sometimes
you don't have to make the decisions
yourself at all
okay now let's not forget about the
maneuver
well now we can go knight a4 and knight
c5 the problem is he might take our
knight
so i won't i don't want to do this just
so he takes a knight
so let's think let's think
one thing that you want to do here right
we want to complete our development the
time has come
for us to complete our developments
where should we put our bishop
which which seems like a good square
and this is going to be
counter-intuitive to some people there
should be two
now i know some of you are thinking wait
a second what is this doing the bishop
is just blunted by the pawns but guess
what as i've said before
in some positions you want to develop
your pieces you can assign some of your
pieces the very legitimate task
of supporting other pieces in other
words good bad bishops defend good pawns
these pawns i think everybody would
agree with me are super important we
don't want to abandon these pawns to the
wolves
and so we assign one piece we say okay
you're on that duty you're on defensive
duty ah the bishop is like and jonathan
rosen
grandmaster from scotland he calls this
talking to your pieces
i know it makes me look like a
psychopath but i'm like imagining the
bishop's like no i don't want to defend
i want to attack
hey you you stay home for the greater
good you stay home you defend the pawns
let the other pieces do the heavy
lifting for now
okay we don't want to give this bishop
away where should we put this bishop
should we move it back to f1 but can we
keep it on this diagonal where it's a
little bit more active yeah
bishop c2 then we can dispense with the
knight by playing queen up to d2
coordinating our rooks and chasing the
knight away
we can also play g3 although that's a
little bit weakening i would be hesitant
about playing that move
okay let's see what he does a very
complicated game you guys can see that a
closed center
entails a lot of complexity that's just
the way that it is
but i hope that i'm at least partially
guiding you successfully through
some of the like logic behind you know
these seemingly weird moves
well the reason g3 is weakening just
pushing out upon in front of your king
is weakening because it weakens certain
squares it leaves undefended certain
squares next to your king
that might not be a big issue if your
opponent doesn't have pieces on the king
side
right which he doesn't so g3 here is
fine
but when you have a task that you want
to fulfill you want to fulfill it in a
way
that does as many things as possible and
here rooks are not coordinated so queen
d2
has the additional benefit of
coordinating the rooks
now one thing i observe here which might
seem like a random observation folks but
it's super important
bishop on d7 what can you tell me about
this bishop guys what specifically look
at that bishop very carefully
squint at the bishop what can you tell
me about it
it's locked it doesn't have any squares
which means boom potentially if we can
play e6 here with
absolute but that doesn't matter he's
got a pawn on e6 well guess what
let's involve our friend mr tactics
let's put on our tactical sunglasses
what do we see here we can get this pawn
out of e6 we can force that pawn out
by playing knight takes d5 and then e6
so the moment he played rook c8 because
i've solved so many problems in my life
my brain sort of supplies this
automatically but you can also start the
engine manually you can sort of ask
yourself at various points
what quantitative or qualitative
observations can i make about some of
his pieces
you particularly want to notice things
like a queen and a king being on the
same diagonal
uh a piece being without any possible
squares which means if you attack that
piece with a pawn
then you win that piece and once you
fire up the engine like that you start
seeing moves like knight takes d5 now
why is this a good trade-off
why am i taking for granted that it's a
good idea to trade
essentially our knight for his bishop
who can explain to me what is the
positive
externality and this is actually the
main reason this is good for us
first of all the fact that his bishop is
gone means that the d5 pawn is weak but
guess what the e
file opens the e file is the main artery
to his king even if he castles
once we get two rooks on the e file his
position is going to fall apart he's got
too many weaknesses
this bishop on c2 can switch over to b3
and attack the pawn on d5 guess what
he doesn't have a light-squared bishop
anymore that means he has to assign the
task of defending that
to a rook that's not a very efficient
use of resources so what should we do
here
what should we do here
it's 5 30 a.m guys but all this support
all these gifted subs
i'm not gonna lie it's keeping me going
it's giving me tons of energy so
i really appreciate this week let's keep
the hype is just rolling on the hype is
absolutely real today
so we double rooks now we can go bishop
b3
i might stream all night i don't even
care i'm young
this is what i'm doing this is what i
gotta freaking do i'm taking a vacation
over new year
i can give myself fully this is the this
is the least i can do given the level of
support guys
the least i can do okay
so we have several ways now of
approaching his king
we can triple oh here's here we go again
aaron's still gifting a sub to zipper 12
3 4 5. 101 bits what should we do
what should we do
how can we make substantive improvements
to our position and there's multiple
ways of approaching his position now i
like the move bishop b3
employing the bishop and attacking the
pawn and now do you guys want to see the
most five-head maneuver of all freaking
tigers get
we have a very five head maneuver
assuming he goes rook d8
this is going to make some jaws drop
okay
let's reason logically the pawn on d5 is
weak
agreed right no this shouldn't be
controversial
okay i'll show you guys after the game
he ended up blundering his queen which
is what happens when you put people
under this much pressure
completely understandable completely
understandable let me show you guys this
good game good game now in order to find
this maneuver i need to show you guys a
game i've shown this game before i need
to show you guys an idea
ex cather thank you for the prime this
idea is called the rubenstein maneuver
now the rubenstein maneuver comes from
big reveal coming up akiba rubenstein i
can't you can't believe it
the rubenstein maneuver refers to a
particular positioning of the queen
okay it refers to a particular queen
maneuver that akiba rubenstein one of
the strongest players of the early
20th century the dude 7195 think the sub
implemented in a game in 1907 against
david yanovsky
and since then this maneuver has become
a very popular idea of improving your
position
so let me show you guys the original
rubenstein maneuver then i'll show you
guys how i
implemented that idea in one of my games
and finally i guarantee it
it will make it very easy to find the
correct idea here
so yanovsky against rubenstein they're
playing in tournament in the czech
republic in 1907.
and you know it's just a position right
yanovsky is pretty happy with himself
he's got a nice blockade
he's got more space but rubenstein finds
an incredible
idea here what rubenstein says akiba's
like
ah man my queen is not doing anything
it's just sitting there
where do i want my queen he's like wait
a second i want my queen
sniping at him from a7 he's like looks
at it and he's like man i really want
that queen on that diagonal what does he
do
what does rubenstein do tell me his next
three moves his next four moves
he's like wait what if the queen comes
to c5 and maybe venice can help prepare
b5
chipping at white's pawn chain boom boom
boom boom queen comes to c5
and the main idea the rubenstein
maneuver is
the path of the queen to this square or
one of these four corners okay and in
many positions that's a very unexpected
and very good way of improving the
queen's position
it's 5 30 in nc ask me if i care
ask me if i care
i may or may not have woken up at 5 00
pm i don't care
because this is more important it looks
like a waste of moose but it's not
look at how sexy this queen is it's
right in the center it's pressuring the
rook it's preparing b5
it can it can infiltrate all the way to
d2 and rubenstein ends up winning the
game
when he uses the queen to open up the a
file
and he wins the end game well the reason
that he has
time to do this is because the position
is closed
everybody listen up i don't care how
sleepy you are this is freaking
important okay
it's freaking important now let's write
down i-85
when the position is closed you have a
lot more time to do stuff than when the
position is open
that is like the most important
principle of closed positions
in the vast majority of closed positions
the rules it's like everything slows
down it's like you're astronauts in
space you're floating around
okay um so maneuvers that take four
moves which would be
unthinkable in an open position now
become more than thinkable they become
very possible 100 bids thank you
now is that a rule is that a hard and
fast rule no and what you have to
understand when the position is closed
you need to
preemptively realize whether and who has
the capacity to open up the position
because if you fall asleep and you just
want to move the pieces around okay you
move the queen around
the position is closed and all of a
sudden your opponent opens up the
position and your queen is somewhere in
timbuktu and the position opens up
then guess what you're caught with your
pants down and
nobody wants that so you've got to be
very careful and you've got to make sure
that your opponent doesn't have the
capacity to open up the position
thank you ct squires that is how you
should often think about closed
positions
but here white certainly doesn't have
that capacity
to open up the position i mean if he
plays f4 then he does himself more
damage
he does himself more damage
okay um and so that's the reason you can
do this now
fast forward 113 years
to the career of a terrible chess player
named daniel nerdetsky
who in the year one second
oh my god oh my god another five we got
another five gifted in the year 2010 was
rated
2370 fiji tournament in france
in a tiny village called capella grand
next to dunkirk anybody seen that movie
that's the city where this tournament
was held
it's round one i've flown in the
previous night i'm jet lagged as hell
i get the pairings i'm playing a
freaking gm 2570 one of the strongest
french players jean-marc digreb
i'm like oh my god i'm falling asleep at
the board game starts at 6 p.m
i'm like whatever you know what i said
the upward i said [ __ ] it
i'm playing i'm playing the most
creative dania style chess in the
possible i don't care if i lose quickly
and then the following position arises
after 10 moves the following position
arises after 10 moves
okay he plays a philidor by the way
he plays a philidor
the following position arises after 10
moves
you guys should see the board now and
you guys should see the board okay
so i look at this position and i'm like
well white has more space
why is more space but then i noticed the
bishop i'm like wait a second bishop's
pressuring f7
can i attack f7 thank you for the five
gift thank you so much
jaywood can i attack that pawn and i was
like akiba
rubenstein is talking to me 1907. ruben
steinovsky what did i do
queen b1 this is a novelty and i think
it's a really really sexy move
because i get my queen to a2 i put
tremendous pressure on this pawn
and i later use this battery to open up
the position
and then this position arose this
position or as i sacked upon
white to play and find a crushing
combination
white to play and find a crushing
combination using this battery
come on guys who wants to earn a sub for
me
95 is almost almost works but here he's
got rook takes e5
he's got rook takes c5 and queen takes
h5 i know you guys are thinking of this
but unfortunately he first takes on e5
then he takes on h5 instead
beautiful bishop f7 pin
and the queen on a2 wins me the freaking
game because he can't take the night
he's pinned he's got to move the king i
trade queens i take the rook
and look at how overwhelming my attack
is he's got two pieces for a rook and a
pawn
so it's not the material that kills and
what kills him
is my attack on his king bishop e6
white to play find the crusher
this is a discovered attack against the
bishop a very simple move
the knight wants to move and inflict as
much damage as possible
if he takes rook takes c6 and rook takes
c6 as crushing
my opponent goes king f7 trying to
shelter himself
white to play and win and this is the
actual crusher
and sorry i don't mean to flex on people
but knight this is one of my fondest
games
forcing him to give up another exchange
two-piece two rooks for three pieces
is a huge material advantage and i went
on to win
and i went on to win with a very nice
combination
and the game lasted 45 moves and i
managed to win and queen a2
a novelty queen b1 queen a2 was what
actually won me the game
okay so sorry for that detour the
rubenstein maneuver i even wrote an
article on it
now i want you to come back to the speed
run with that information in your mind
and i want you to remember that what we
did with the last move bishop b3 is
attacked upon
much like i attacked my opponent's pawn
on f7 it's just a different pawn
so after rook cd8 who can tell me what
idea
white has here well
that's not the fastest it's math now
this isn't the fastest maneuver what is
the fastest way of getting the queen to
a2
boom bishop c3 and queen freaking a2 i
don't even care if that's the best move
but that's the sexiest or bishop a1
bishop c3 or bishop a1 and queen a2
loading up the battery on the pawn
okay that's how pattern recognition
works bishop's e3 is better actually
bishop c3 doesn't allow bishop a1 he's
got a tactic he can play bishop takes
before
oh my god that's actually like the
second that's actually the best move
that's actually like the second best
move i just turned the computer on
queen c bishop c3 queen a2
and that's how this freaking stuff works
well this position has opened up because
you've got the e file open but let's
look at the whole game now
not too uh sorry for the very long
detour okay
um so we had a french i played the
advance c5 c3
and the first part of the game the
battle revolves around the d4 pawn so he
attacks it i defend it now the move a3
became popular about 20 years ago when
people were like let me get this pawn
out of c5 and while i'm doing it let me
expand on the queen side and get some
space
black has many ways of playing this
position black has many ways of playing
this position
uh c4 is not great thank you the gaming
mic let's keep that hype going another
sub
that's what we're talking about thank
you for the two months so a3 b4 is
possible you could also play bishop d3
here
exploiting the same concept that taking
is not possible due to bishop b5
there's many possible lines here i
played a3
he goes f6 he chips away at the base of
the pawn chain but we know
that chipping away at the base of the
pawn chain isn't usually as effective as
chipping away at the tip of the pawn
chain
so he goes f6 now instead of this uh
black has several other moves uh
i think the main line here i'm not a
specialist i think knight g7 is possible
where is the knight going and why is it
going there and why is this the main
move why does this make sense doesn't he
like block the development of the bishop
thank you guys knight to f5 attacking
the pawn
not to g6 guys remember that keep your
eye on the main idea
almost at 70 70 200 i can't believe it
knight f5 to attack d4 white goes b4
knight f5 bishop b2 so you get this
situation where like both sides are
really attacking the d4 pawn
white is defending it black is attacking
it very complicated position
very complicated position f6 we can
ignore by playing b4
now what i want people to understand
right what should you guys be thinking
f takes e5t takes e5 why is this good
for white
like wait a second girl you have a pawn
on d5
it's a protected pass pawn you're giving
black a protected pass pawn you're
ruining your own pawn chain
and now you have like an isolated pawn
on e5 but what you need to understand is
first of all white's got the d4 square
under control
later i can place a knight on d4 and
blockade the square in front of the pass
pawn
the other thing what i want you guys to
see the pawn on e6
the bishop on c8 that's the famous
french bishop it ain't going anywhere
and the last thing is that king on e8 is
super weak
because by playing f6 black has weakened
this diagonal
right and later you could try to get a
queen to h5 and that could be absolutely
devastating
okay that could be absolutely
devastating yeah a5 is one of the main
moves here stopping a
stopping b4 but here white can go a4 and
bishop b5
so this is a very complex situation
where both sides have their advantages
and i don't really agree with the move
a6 but i like the fact that jupster
didn't take on e5
does this all make sense guys i know
that was a i know that was a handful
please don't be afraid to ask me to
repeat stuff
very nice so i get why a6 was played but
this is too slow
i actually think that maybe knight g7 is
still the best move
or bishop d7 to develop the pieces
gigahertz if there is something specific
you'd like me to repeat
please don't be afraid so
um i think f6 is inaccurate okay i think
f6 is a little too weakening
now i think bishop d7 is best just
develop the pieces maybe put a rook on
c8
maybe get the open file f6 is thematic
but i think here it's a little bit too
weakening thank you namiya for the prime
now after a6 i'm able to quickly develop
the rest of my pieces
i develop my knight remember flexibility
we don't develop the bishop until the
very end
now in the end bishop queen takes d4
just to show you guys bishop g6 is a
discovered check winning the queen
that's without this idea this whole
variation
would not have worked and guess what
what enables this to move f6
that's why f6 is so damaging this
diagonal
is super important in this line not only
because of the possibility of a queen
appearing on h5
but also because of the possibility of
bishop g6
so if you play f5 here and you're like
let me shut this down
that also has a drawback and you need to
get used to thinking of moves in terms
of their drawbacks
right what people often do they
understand why a move is played that's a
form of positional tunnel vision
you have to also consider what a move's
drawback is this takes the pressure off
of the e5 pawn this takes the foot off
the gas pedal
which means white has won the battle
over the center and now white can swing
the knight around to c5
okay so what happens in this position is
black gets super super cramped
i can even show you guys a game from my
chess career
from very early in my chess career from
2005 where something very similar
happens
once black's play in the center dries up
once black's play and the center dries
up um
black's position becomes very miserable
and this idea of getting the knight to
c5
you will see it in many games where
things go very wrong
this is from uh the world youth chess
championship 2005.
this is um the first international
tournament i played that's why i have a
soft spot for france this tournament was
played in france
okay
this is uh one of my fun fond early
games okay
so this is a position that arose in the
game but watch what happened so it was a
french
and it was an advanced and i played a3
and then i played b4 and he actually
played correctly but what happened in
this game
is his counter play quickly dried up he
played super passively
he should have played f6 like once
you're castled
then you can play f6 but for some reason
he just kind of
he just kind of folded over and he he
allowed me to get a knight to c5
and here i played i made a very
instructive move
well he wanted to trade the light
squared bishop so i get that but it was
just too passive i played
dc why so why why am i giving him a
protected passer and if you were paying
attention
you should know the answer to this one
like what is the redeeming factor here
for white
it's the fact that yeah it's the fact
that i have control over the square
in front of the past pawn in this case i
have control over the d4 square
look at this amazing knight look at
these pawns look at the space advantage
and i just checkmated him on the king
side
i just piled up on the king side i've
shown charlie the end of this game
and i just demolished him i mean i'll
fast forward through the rest of the
game
there was just no counter play wow
bellow has played the same tournament
amazing
uh there was no counter play i just
crushed him and um
i didn't even really do anything
extraordinary he had no play on the
queen side this entire game
so that's why the french is such a
conceptually difficult opening
there it's very high stakes if if black
isn't able to succeed
in the center then he gets this
miserable position so
hopefully this clarifies things a little
bit for you guys hopefully this
clarifies things just a tad
and something very similar very similar
position happened in the game in spirit
black's counter play dried up i got his
pieces back knight takes d5 is crushing
because of e6 winning the bishop back
and the e file is absolutely
destruction and he blunders the the
queen but
this bishop c3 a2 idea would have been
absolutely devastating
absolutely devastating